nothing can keep me down I've been
attacked by terrorists asteroids film
critics music critics restaurant critics
divorce lawyers male pattern baldness
and none of it none of it stopped me
because I am still Bruce will
people asked me why i did this.first
was it because one of the last guys who
did it became president
hell no why would I want to be President
when I can just keep being Bruce
Willis I did this rows for one reason
and for one reason only
to settle something once and for all now
please listen very carefully
diehard is not a Christmas movie
[Music]
it's a goddamn Bruce Willis movie so
yippee-ki-yay - all of you
good night
[Music]
[Applause]
you